this is the new national hymn
and cows are the emblem on the new coat
of arms
the village of las is about to become a
principality
a many state with a passport diplomatic
relations and of course a government
says the long-standing mayor of the
village
you are in the governor's palace the
future government headquarters
our two co-princes will be the president
of the french republic and the bishop of
bayonne
the council will be turned into a
government and i'll be the delegate of
these two co-princes i'll be the head of
the government
is due to become a principality next
year and the 123 inhabitants of the
village will become its subjects
visitors will be expected to pass
through
customs check the cars to make sure they
don't have weapons or illicit objects
the principality will be peace loving
and glamorous
the mayor invited brigitte bardot to
come and live here 20 years ago when she
announced she'd had enough of the
riviera
she didn't in the end but she did become
friends with the mayor
he says las is a perfect alternative to
the kota zour with its chateau for regal
events and its flowing river
instead of having billionaires yachts
anchored there'll be rafts from time to
time or canoes and kayaks or a great
pyrenees mountain dog paddling in the
water
that's just as good as the beach in nice
but the project is not so much about
glamour as protest
like many in france the village of las
feels it's been neglected by the
government in paris there's not enough
money coming into the coffers
people who work in the local crafts
industry hope they'll get an economic
boost they expect new customers for
their basque berets as well as support
they always say that craftsmen are
france's greatest enterprise and that's
true but who believes us no one
those we elect don't believe us
we hope we'll be joined by more artisans
maybe we'll get more attention if people
talk of the principality of los
the local farmers are also looking
forward to the village's new status
if it's like monaco fine as long as
there's no more taxes because at the
moment we're paying a lot of them
but not everyone is that enthusiastic
we're letting the mayor do what he likes
but we're a bit worried a bit skeptical
people tend to make fun of us when we
say we're from lass and ask oh are you
the princess of las vegas
last may have a national anthem but as a
principality it's unlikely to gain
recognition from the government in paris